hi in this video i'll introduce you to
datastream then i'll walk through
setting up real-time replication from
cloud sql to bigquery i'm gabe weiss a
developer advocate for google cloud
datastream is a serverless change data
capture or cdc replication service data
stream makes it easy to replicate data
from operational databases into bigquery
reliably and with minimal latency
datastream provides a simple integrated
experience to guide you through every
step of the process it's serverless so
you don't need to worry about managing
or monitoring instances and continuous
data replication means you can unify
data across multiple sources and
applications and make it accessible in
real time to help power a wide range of
use cases including analytics database
migrations event-driven architectures ai
and machine learning data lakes and more
whether your source database is
on-premises self-hosted in google cloud
or running on another cloud datastream
helps you quickly unlock the benefits of
real-time replication now let's walk
through the data stream experience
you can easily find data stream by
searching for it in the search box at
the top of the cloud platform console
you can also find it in the google cloud
console navigation under analytics
to get started you'll create a stream
this represents the end-to-end process
of streaming changes from your source
database to your destination
first let's define some basic
information about the stream
i want to replicate data from a postgres
database into bigquery
once i've defined my source and
destination types datastream shows me
the configuration required for
successful streaming
data stream is unique in that it
reflects all the configuration
requirements directly within the
creation process to take out the
guesswork involved
for example since i chose postgres as my
source i can see the requirements for
setting up the necessary logging
configuration and permissions
after confirming the necessary
prerequisites i'm ready to define my
source
i can do this by creating a connection
profile a resource that represents the
information needed to connect to a
database
these profiles aren't locked to an
individual stream this means i can reuse
profiles if i want to and also allows me
to hand off creating the source
configuration to someone else in my
organization who's in charge of
connecting to the database
i've already created a connection
profile for my postgres database so i'll
select it
whether i create my source connection
profile now or use one i created in
advance i can test connectivity to make
sure datastream is able to reach it
datastream supports both public and
private connectivity methods to easily
and securely connect to sources wherever
they're hosted be it on google cloud
on-premises or on other cloud providers
once the connectivity test passes i can
continue to configure the stream for my
source
next i need to specify some replication
properties for my postgres database
and then i want to select objects that
this stream should pull from my source
using the selection ui i can define
which schemas and tables to stream for
my database
i'll select a couple of tables from the
employees schema
for the objects i selected i also need
to bring over the historical data so
i'll leave the backfill mode set to
automatic
now i'm ready to define the destination
for my stream here again i can create a
new connection profile for my
destination or use an existing one i'll
select a bigquery connection profile i
have ready to go
now data stream allows me to specify how
to load the data into bigquery i can
choose between creating a new data set
for every schema in the source database
or create all my tables in bigquery
inside a single data set for this demo i
want to create a data set for every
schema
and to help keep my data in bigquery
organized i also want to prefix each
data set with demo
that was easy i've connected and
configured my stream all this left is to
validate the end-to-end stream
configuration and start moving data
validation passed successfully i can
trust that my stream will run smoothly
i'll create and start the stream to run
it immediately
data stream will perform the historical
backfill and continuously replicate
changes as they happen i can monitor
different metrics of the stream such as
throughput latencies and more
with data now continuously being
replicated into bigquery i can query
real-time data and get up-to-date
information on all my business processes
build reports and predictive analytics
with machine learning and easily provide
secure access to my data across the
organization
and that's it i've quickly and easily
shown you how to continuously ingest
changes from a postgres database into
bigquery using data stream and since
data stream is serverless it will
automatically scale up and down to
handle my data volumes and maintain
minimal latency
data stream is the fast easy and
reliable way to seamlessly replicate
data from your database to bigquery to
support analytics and it can also be
used to capture change streams to
support database replication event
driven architectures and more it's
serverless high performance and easy to
use now it's your turn to give it a try
you can get started from the google
cloud console or learn more at
cloud.google.com datastream thanks for
watching
[Music]
you